what does a developer do day-to-day well
one thing I think you need to learn
about is a Kanban board I discussed them
in my previous two videos but we're
finally gonna get into the details stay
tuned for more okay so I do start my day
by checking my emails and slack but if
those two things do not reveal any
pertinent pressing issues then I go
straight to the conference or a Kanban
board is a workflow visualization tool
it helps you see the flow of where the
application is at the current moment so
I did not get permission to show you my
works Kanban board but I do have two
tools that I want to share with you to
help you create your own Kanban board
with user stories for your personal
projects or to help you get started and
learn about Kanban boards before your
first job so we're going to create a
Kanban board for sniffs and was an
application for dogs to meet other dogs
in their City now for the first tool I
want to show you is Trello Trello can be
used for your everyday life to help you
organize different to-do lists and tasks
that you have or it can be used for a
Kanban board to help you organize your
own application
now the subtext for Kombat board is
simple and at its basics it's just AIT's
doulas you do to do doing and done and
those are your columns that are gonna
house your user stories okay so a common
board is like a big to do this it helps
you visualize that workflow and takes a
user story from beginning to completed
so we're gonna create a compound board
of our own we're gonna create it for
schnitzels
I want it to be public so that somebody
else can join and we're just going to do
the basis of basis that you need for any
contract for it and that is to do doing
and done that's it simple right so then
we're gonna add user stories but for the
sake of this example I'm just going to
do something like ethics so maybe you
want to have somebody design the
homepage you want to create that
homepage maybe you want to have sign up
in our sign-in page and then from our
last video we talked about having the
profile page alright so those are your
user stories now in Trello I know that
you can share with other users the share
tab is here and that helps you
collaborate with other people so say I
had other users and maybe Amanda was my
designer and she decided to decide the
homepage she would move that car to the
doing lane because she is officially
working on that user story and maybe I'm
the developer and I'm gonna go ahead and
create that homepage you do not need to
have the designs to create the initial
homepage you just want to have like the
initial text and maybe the links that
actually go to different places so we're
working on those say two weeks or so
goes by and I've finished creating the
homepage and she's still working on the
design so maybe I'm done with that part
but I may need to create another user
story to apply those designs to the
homepage so that's part of agile you
want these user stories to be flexible
so that you can go back and make sense
of what you have and make sure that you
have everything in order okay so that is
the basics of the basis of a Kanban
board you can create it easily and
Trello for any of your projects and
it'll help you visualize that workflow
for you and any teammates that you might
have
on your project now I do want to point
out that Trello does have some cool
features you can do what's called
power-ups okay add-ons so say you wanted
to add on slack
also there are developer tools so you
can add github features and I see that
you can also add some read me or
markdown features which is a part of a
developer's world so it you can add a
lot of different things to help you
through organizing your own projects and
this is a great way to get started
before you get your first job or just
for any project that you may have so
this is making sense for you so far go
ahead and put coding like a boss in the
comments below if not hopefully I will
help you hash out those issues with the
next tool that I want to talk about and
that tool is github
okay so trial had a lot of bright
features it was simple easy and it can
be used for any project that you might
have as well as any life goals that you
need to organize but specifically for
developers I think github is a great
place to house everything from your code
to also using their Kanban board feature
so we're going to go through that now so
I'm gonna go ahead and create a project
called sniffs hmm
and wolf so it's an app that lets your
pets meet other pets and the neighbor I
can't smell guys neighborhood it's
public I almost initialize it with Remy
and we are going to create that with
other tool so if you're not familiar
with github github allows you to save
snapshots of all your code and allows
you to go back in time if you make any
errors you can go back to a previous
version and use that version instead of
the one that's messed up that's the
simple explanation of github so github
also has a way for you to make conman
board you'll go up here to projects and
then you will
your project no British or TAS and we're
going to create a project sniffs and
whoops I'm not gonna have a description
because I feel like our party described
it we're gonna add a column so this
column is going to be to do just like
before and then we're gonna have doing
and finally done so this is just like
Trello simple and easy and then you're
gonna go ahead and create the same user
stories so we're gonna create a design
we're going to create the homepage we're
also going to create sign-in page and
finally we're going to create the
profile package I want to point out that
your Kanban board can get very big for
example at my job every application has
to be 508 compliant
that means that every application has to
be accessible to people with
disabilities and it needs to be able to
be read by screen readers or any other
tools that somebody with a disability
might be using in order to view that
application so I'm gonna add that here
it's gonna go between doing and done so
we're gonna say ready for 508 you can
easily move any columns wherever you
need them to be and then we're gonna add
doing 508 we're gonna add pass and one
last one
oops sorry there add fail
now this is what I would see on my board
we have different kinds of views because
we have columns that can be within
columns so the main header would be 508
and then within that big column you
would see ready doing the packs or fail
so this is part of the workflow because
I will work on the user story and then I
will pass it on to the 508 team and
they'll subscriber wait - you won't have
to go through the same process of doing
to do doing pass or fail and then once
it goes from there it will go to a whole
other team who will go to the user
acceptance testing and those people will
make sure that that user test passes the
criteria that you gave it so remember
when I said that that last part of the
user story is to help you test that on
that task that is for not only the
developer not only the 5 way people but
for the users to test that user stores
and make sure that it follows the
requirements that they need ok so I just
wanted to point out a few other features
that might help you on your journey so
we're just gonna go through riddles just
a little bit say that someone came in
and they're still working on creating
designs say I came in and I mine went
through 508 or it's ready for 508 and
let's just say another user passed 508
and they decided to move their card over
to the done Lane also this done Lane can
be interpreted - ready for production so
you're ready to push up that code to
your production environment also I just
want to point out that you can have some
interesting features so like creating a
checklist so maybe this is redundant
because it's already a big old to-do
list but maybe you want to make sure
that you talk to the product owner
and that's going to create a checkbox so
that you can check it just as if it were
out to do this and this rule is also I
created an issue just for this and you
can add those issues directly to your
board so you would go to add a card and
you'll see this issue right here and you
can sorry about that
add a card and add this to your board
there we go
so now you know how to use the basics of
github for Kanban board purposes you can
house all that workflow into one place
okay so I really encourage you to get to
know Trello or get hooked on boards in
more detail and start using it for your
projects this will help you prepare for
your first job or just have a better
workflow for the project that you're
working on be it real life any goals
that you may have or specifically a
project or an application that you're
building on your own time so if you like
this video if you enjoyed it and you
want to come back for more
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
below I'd love to see more of you and
also I'd love to see you on Twitter and
or Instagram so if you enjoyed this
video go ahead take some pictures of
your Kanban board some of your user
stories and at me or hash tag coding
like a boss alright I'll see you later
bye